the nation know the world
that's right here we are world baby
people are following us
hanging on every word
[Applause]
ready to
no i won't say it i was going to say
ready do no no no we are ready to go to
war baby
love and peace in a beautiful hopeful
way that's right we are underground in
vault 77
we're in hunger games have begun we're
in a fema facility we're trapped right
now ladies and gentlemen it might look
like our regular it might look like a
regular setup but the government is
forcing us to do this [ __ ] branded
brandon's forcing us to stream and and
say all the things mean things about
republicans we love republicans let us
out
in truth i'm actually more black-pilled
i think even today than i was
uh following you start watching the show
i told you to watch no not yet dude
you're gonna be so pissed when you start
watching that show hassan was telling me
to watch the show on hbo we own the city
we own the city and it's like i love
that [ __ ] because you said it's about
like corrupted police department it's a
real story about the horrific criminal
actions that and the rampant abuse that
the baltimore police department
both covered up engaged in turned the
other cheek supported encouraged yeah uh
specifically on the gun uh the gun trace
task force
it's a part of like the violent crimes
investigative division you know they
have vice they have you know the gun you
know those are the gun guys
uh and
it's awesome it's real stories like
every single
part of that show from start to finish
seems fictionalized because you're like
there's no way this is real but like
every single thing that happened
happened in real life
yeah i love that i know about the
baltimore police department because the
wire is one of my favorite shows i know
how [ __ ] up and david simon also wrote
it so i mean or co-produced the same guy
who made the wire yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
let's go right now yeah
yeah so i'm gonna watch that but
the reason i'm blackpilled this morning
is because the supreme court is
basically
come down with two rulings today one
that's right baby is that they made the
miranda right you never no longer have
to read the miranda right when you
arrest someone
which is you guys know it's you have the
rights to remain silent anything you say
can and will be used
against you in a court of law that whole
thing yeah they don't have to say that
anymore yeah you can like nominate
yourself [ __ ] the fifth amendment
you can you can totally incriminate
yourself i think the less rights for
people more more rights for police is
the way we need to be moving and guns
guns police and citizens can be [ __ ]
yeah i think yeah exactly and and also
fetuses
fetuses are everything yeah by the way
it's kind of funny because also jewels
got banned this week yeah
[ __ ] up so so they say
so they say on one hand
nobody can have jewels because it's too
dangerous yet everybody can have a gun
anywhere at any time
yeah does that seem uh
logically consistent to you absolutely
yeah 100
yeah there's there's a real there's a
real pandemic of gunlessness happening
in this country and i'm glad that the
supreme court is addressing it pvp
unlocked in new york that's right
it's new york is that's right the towers
we got pvp zone everyone can have a gun
battle royale yeah yes or the sick the
other one that hassan's touching on here
is that you know new york has a really
strict gun laws
uh
and uh they have this one clause that
says you have to prove that you have a
very good reason
to get a
uh concealed handgun permit yeah and
then the supreme court said hell no bro
we want it to be the wild west around
here [ __ ] states rights
[ __ ] states rights unless it's abortion
then we think every state should decide
yeah which is coming next you should be
able to like in louisiana
legally uh uh
try to criminalize sending abortion
pills into the state
and also which good luck i mean [ __ ] you
louisiana uh but also
we will if you
if you are caught administering abortion
pills to someone not the patient herself
but anyone else like
what do you do like anyone else like
helping facilitate an abortion gets five
years hard labor hard labor what is this
north korea dude what does hard labor
mean that's louisiana baby
what age is this yeah the louisiana
state penitentiary is a a robust
business of that that runs on slavery
straight up like it's a it's a literal
plantation hard labor
look up any photos any documentaries
about angola or louisiana state
penitentiary and you'll realize like
second degree uh manslaughter charges uh
is is life life in prison so many young
like 19 year old
uh
18 year old black men just in prison
doing hard labor out in the sun yeah
straight up like doing i mean they're
i don't think they pick cotton uh i
don't know if they pick cotton
specifically but they do everything like
literally everything car mechanics
just uh you know they are doing
agricultural work
everything
oh boy
there was a famous sheriff in louisiana
that once said uh you know we can't be
letting these uh these these you know
good behavior uh
misdemeanor having uh black people out
because they're make good slaves
basically
when did he say that
you might be thinking like you know 1910
no uh
like 2016.
can you someone find that yeah look up
like louisiana sheriff slave labor we
can't be having no black people around
around here boy no he that's good labor
yeah he he basically said if we let out
people on good behavior we lose workers
that's normal yeah here it is oh 2017 27
oh even more money even more recently so
let's get a look at this modern take by
louisiana
we can't be having none of them black
folks running around here boy
those crops ain't gonna be picking
themselves yep
and people be like racism's dead yeah
there's no such thing as racism does
someone find that quote
well i mean i could read it to you i
already have it and i can pull it as
well yeah just read it that's fine yeah
pull it up i'll just pull it i'll just
pull it right here
i don't know oh it's on video let's go
can you listen to it here or no can you
pull it up dan or or zach or whoever
if you can't pull it up here just uh
i'll just read it
now let's watch the video
okay is his screen not working what's
going on
you want me to put it into the discord
i can pull it up what
is his is his thing not working down
it's all good
but can he not play audio from his
it's all good it's all good um i'll just
read the quote
wait i got it right here i'll play the
video all right play the video i'd
rather watch this dumb [ __ ] at paris
jails in louisiana the state in order to
save money rather than holding prisoners
uh
way
hundred years ago the parish
that's not actual but a lot of years ago
the parish sheriff started holding
prisoners and they were willing to take
a lesser amount than the state was
charged for
was having to pay
we have since i've been the sheriff of
cattle paris we're not i don't run a
place out there i don't want
uh state prisoners okay they are a
necessary evil to keep the doors open
that we keep a few or keep some out
there and that's the ones that you can
work that's the ones that can pick up
trash the work release programs but
guess what those are the ones that
they're releasing
in addition to the in addition to the
bad ones
and i call these bad
in addition to them releasing some good
ones that we use every day to to wash
cars to change oil in our cars to cook
in the kitchens to do all that where we
save money well they're going to let
them out
the ones that we use in our work release
program they're gonna let them out and
they're saying you can take a little
worse criminal
because we're gonna we're gonna loosen
up the standards that you can use them
and so you instead of somebody with four
years left in a sentence working
at a factory somewhere now they're going
to say we're going to let you use
somebody with five years well i'm not
doing that
no at some point a person it's more
beneficial for them to run off
and so there's so many aspects of this
there was one law enforcement person on
this whole committee
i wish i'd been on there
uh why weren't you
well i don't know but uh i would have
probably spoken what i was thinking and
and uh
but anyway and like i say i'm not being
critical of the entire effort
i'm not being critical on this guy's
going to hell and all those people
behind him too yes sir yep um straight
up he says it like i don't want people
to come out and be released on good
behavior because they are slaves they
save us money yeah um that's not i don't
think that's the point of prison i think
or maybe it is maybe that is here but i
thought prison was supposed to
rehabilitate people and send them back
to be yeah if you're a [ __ ] to be
productive members of society but yeah
but here it's actually just for slave
labor
yeah the work of these programs that
he's talking about by the way work for
the oil and gas industry as well like
they do pick
um they do pick uh i don't know i guess
they do pick cotton as well they they're
just
they have work release programs uh for
for uh prisoners they let out on good be
or not let out on good behavior but
prisoners like convicted of a
misdemeanor
that that still for some reason are just
in prison for an extremely long time
um
can do work with these programs where
they get paid like again like two cents
an hour yeah you know what i mean and
then the state takes and maintains the
profits of
their labor
that's disgusting this is so [ __ ] up
dude this guy bro he's like are you law
enforcement or like a business person i
mean ethan you're you're you're supposed
to be [ __ ] uh doing the law not
thinking about capital and [ __ ] you'd be
shocked maybe to find out the origins of
police literally started as this they
were uh you know
asset extractors they basically would
they they were slave patrol that was the
original inception of policing in the
south
before we had like sheriffs and whatever
we before we had a system like that the
entire goal of uh what we now understand
is the police is is uh slave patrol
they would capture one of these sites
did you really need to blackpill me
further
i'm i mean this is the reality you know
this is the reality of of uh american
history which is unfortunately not
really taught in schools and that's why
so many people turn them you know so
many people turn a blind eye to all of
this that's still ongoing in america
slavery is legal in america going back
to that though going back to the supreme
court case
um you know things that make it a little
bit easier to to
jail people even if they incriminate
themselves uh the miranda laws are now
taken yes so
these are two decisions and they're all
along party lines which let's just say i
mean
it's just a partisan body now it's 6-3
on everything and all the justices on
the supreme court are just
they're they're groomed uh
uh
christian cultists
um
who who christian fascists honestly
uh based on their decisions here and and
it i mean it's just become such a farce
and next week coming down the pipeline
is the abortion one
that's going to throw it to states
rights and um
and there's there's one i was just
listening to the daily about
they're bringing to the supreme court
some kind of uh
something about the epa like uh they're
gonna hamstring
the president's ability to enact uh
carbon interaction yeah the clean air
act they're they're going to unwind the
clean air act which is seen as one of
the most comprehensive uh that's by a
republican nixon
yeah
so they're [ __ ] i mean i don't know what
to say man we're just so [ __ ] no i
think like this has a this has something
to do with the with the tendency for
profit to fall uh ultimately as a
consequence of
improved
productivity
technological achievements
um
further industrialization
uh and and they have to squeeze out
profits wherever they can
and the only way to do that if you're
not going to engage in innovation which
requires a lot of
capital up front and requires a lot of
failure like big government projects
like the internet
are are not going to happen in a hyper
capitalist dystopia that we exist under
because everyone's looking for
short-term profits every company is
looking for
you know
stock buyback programs like improving
shareholder value no matter how marginal
it is
um so now they are utilizing the
government to eke out as many uh profits
as they possibly can that that are going
to have a significant cost on the lives
of everyday american citizens
this being one of them you know
let's get back to poisoning the
population with lead honestly
lead poisoning will make uh the
inevitable downfall of american empire
more fun at least you know what i mean
it's like free drugs kind of
well that's kind of what happened in
rome in it everyone had lead poisoning
and like they're losing their [ __ ]
mind they used to put lead in their wine
because they thought it tasted good
maybe it does maybe maybe it tastes so
good we should try it yeah i'm just
saying dude don't don't knock it till
you try it should i get sam to yes sam
can we get some how does that work is
there like lick how do you get lead in
your wine is that like a liquid form or
do you just put like a powder form of
lead what does that mean
you know um
a wine expert to come in and uh just
google that i'm genuinely curious
because you know some stuff they say
like we have baby food it's fortified
with iron right hassan and so i think we
should start fortifying it with lead
there's already lead and baby food
there's lead in everything lead
contamination is like uh is
pretty much like that's the reason why
we have not in california
that's the reason why we get warnings in
california
um on on
a number of literally ever consuming
yeah uh wouldn't you know it when you
google around wine and lead
the results it's it's a whole cluster
[ __ ] of how to get lead out of wine oh
man i want to go the other direction
what the [ __ ] you gotta all backwards
yeah yeah we must return to tradition
that's what we need to do yeah uh
or modernity
too much wine sorry
yeah well anyway let's go let's turn our
gaze to something a little
it's not really funny is that
i saw this jordan peterson take
yesterday and it's one of the most
[ __ ] up things i've seen a public
figure tweet out ever
it's pretty incredible
i don't know what has happened to him he
he he has completely fallen he said
of elliott page you know the uh
umbrella academy season three just came
out by the way loved that show i haven't
watched it i watched season three yet
it's so good or i haven't watched season
three yet either just came out but
uh between season two and season three
elliott transitioned
and apparently they're making it part of
the show's narrative
and uh jordan peterson of course has a
problem with that he says remember what
they said in new york post said elliot
page is proud to introduce trans
characters on umbrella academy
nothing really wrong with that title at
all right well jordan peterson says
remember when pride was a sin
and ellen page just had her breasts
removed by a criminal physician she's
like misgendering elliot page even
though the name is right there
um
yeah so
remember when
dude i've done so many videos i feel so
vindicated
like i've done so many videos on jordan
peterson like very clearly being in
transphobe all the way back in like 2016
2017 when he was like first popping off
and people get so mad at me to be like
hassan how dare you say this about
yourselves
this is an openly hostile violent
hateful
but he was doing that he was doing that
stuff like
way more veiled but uh and way more
hidden but he was still doing that stuff
all the way back then too yeah he would
constantly contradict himself by being
like
you're not a real woman if you're
if you're trained you're not a real
woman but then he was like well if
someone asks me i'll all you know i'll
gender them correctly but then he'll be
like i'm not doing it right right i'm
not gendering you correctly he would say
that he'd be like i'll gender you
if you ask i'll do it because i'm polite
but don't compel me like my grandmother
compelled me with her pubic hair yeah
remember one remember when jordan
peterson was respected i mean he should
have never been but he was respected at
a certain point
well
i feel super vindicated for racing those
episodes now too
but like the here's the funny thing
because the conservatives and jordan
peterson they've been on and on about
how uh
children
transitioning and treating children is
wrong
and so they have
they have some
they've relaxed onto that right and
people really this is a grown ass person
yeah how old is is elliot because it's
[ __ ] this is a grown ass person
super successful in show business 35.
this 35 year old person can't make their
own decisions now the doctor is a
criminal i mean [ __ ] you bro because
because
ding ding ding
news flash it was never about
saving the children [ __ ] you and it was
always about like you know trying to
stop trans people from existing
um
by any uh means necessary that was
always the goal
because they talk about like the unfair
advantages people love talking about the
unfair advantages that trans people have
like trans uh women oh yeah in sports
it's like okay well those advantages go
away if if uh
like trans kids are allowed to at least
take uh reversible hormone blockers uh
during puberty right uh or puberty
blockers
and yet they're like nope can't do that
either okay well you just don't want
trans people to exist that's it you just
think it's like weird
yes
yeah that that that's the truth
my favorite part about this tweet
is because jordan peterson
uh the free speech activist the uh uh
marketplace of ideas he turned off
replies
here's the nice thing
he still follows me
anyone that follows him can respond to
his tweets so if you go down
there's three tweets and they're all
roasting him
mine is this is why i raced your
episodes bigot
yeah that's pretty bad to do oh i gotta
get in on that what am i doing i'm
slacking
yeah he does i don't know why let's go
bro get in there i don't know why he
still follows me yeah he follows me too
i was like okay let's do this and then
vosh left one comment that says picture
my former high school principal burning
and help because of the beginning of my
graduation he said he was proud to
introduce the graduating class so there
you go pride is a sin yeah and that's
why that's why
is so [ __ ] up he's never been proud of
her because it's a sin he says listen
i'd like to support you but
it's a sin
i did not [ __ ] my dog
what what
what the [ __ ] that's that
that's that's super suspicious that's
like that's like the uvalde police
department
this is the ualdi police department be
like we did not shoot any of the kids
wait wait jordan did you have more to
say i did not put my dick anywhere near
my dog
okay i got a disclaimer here
that's the ai voice oh my jordan sued
the creator of this so i need to say
explicitly that's not actually jordan's
voice even though play the whole thing
though just for lulz but this is not
jordan peterson's voice i'm just gonna
say that outright i've never done
anything weird with my dogs i did not
[ __ ] my dog
i did not come on my dog oh my god i did
not put my dick anywhere near my dog and
[ __ ] you if you don't like it
it's a parody of shane dawson's i was
about to say like shane dawson jordan
peterson collab is like
the next wave of supreme collapses yes
youtube careers that are falling apart
and then merging the only other comment
here
by the new peel peer review is jordan as
trying to figure out the chaos dragon
and emergency clown nose so there's
three responses and they're all dunking
on him which is awesome and that's that
yeah
what a hateful
bitch-ass [ __ ] loser yeah i wrote him
i wrote him a message i was hoping he
would respond because you know he was
responding to me
before
um
we need to get him on the pod dude
he follows both of us like what the [ __ ]
like just get out come on he doesn't
follow any people either only 500 yeah
come on the pod why is he it's al it
almost feels like he's just only
following the left now what are you
doing
uh
i i tweeted at him hoping he'd see it
open invitation for jordan and for those
of you we can email him we have we have
his email address let's just invite him
and for the people that don't understand
there's a difference between like ethan
platforming jordan peterson and then uh
not feeling comfortable about having
that footage up versus like actually
having a conversation where uh there can
be a little bit more contentious yes
a debate yes if you will i know a lot of
you debate perverts love that so
so maybe we'll just send him an email
and say something like hey
you know we've got this show you follow
both of us we want to have a respectful
conversation obviously coming from
different perspectives yeah
but uh hopefully respectful and then
maybe he can save you you know what i
mean from there you have a bunch of
trans people in the audience a live
audience and also i mean is it is it
really cool to lie when we're reaching
will it be respectful hassan
i be yeah no of course yeah we'll be
respectful
i i have no issue being uh i have no
issue being respectful to people that
i'm that i'm conversing with i mean i i
like you know it's just it's
we'll be respectful when he's here i
don't think jordan peterson is on i
don't think jordan peterson is dumb
enough to
to get like really riled up and say like
really stupid [ __ ] that'll piss me off
so
yeah it'll be respectful but here i
wrote this i wrote him this tweet i
don't know if this is going to help it
says jordan you have completely lost the
plot
anything that was inspiring about you is
long gone you have hoarded yourself out
to the worst among us now you are
nothing more than a useful idiot to the
hordes of faithful bigots you have
forsaken any semblance of decency shame
on you so i don't know if he's gonna
like that one okay
well it's it's getting a little bit
harder for
for us to bring jordan peterson i was so
pissed at that tweet i was like wow they
would think he's super cool if he walks
into like you know treacherous waters
i mean this is a bunker uh deep hidden
under uh pyongyang
in a facility in the democratic people's
republic of korea he'd have to fly out
here obviously it's going to be
difficult but
you know
if he if he did come here he would look
like he'd look like a champion and he
could own us because we're both stupid
as [ __ ] right like i mean we're both not
smart you're smarter than me no no no
i'm i'm an idiot what do you mean i'm
not smart at all i'm just
absolutely dumb points but he's he's a
phd it's easy yeah he's [ __ ] doctor
bro he's he's a doctor yeah
uh a doctor of these
i don't
love where you at i i don't know what
that okay very good i'm sorry
oh no laughter that time
love loves deez nuts jokes
oh
everyone's young and healthy by the way
i don't know if we should play those
sound bites anymore because he did sue
the creator okay and even though we say
on
it's so [ __ ] funny zach and i love it
okay
but we've said here explicitly it's not
real yes and if we keep playing it
we'll have to say that every time okay i
think we just shouldn't okay wait he
didn't sue them what's the story with it
cam
i think he just got really mad that
there's a deep fake of
like a deep fake generator of him out
there and he kind of got
like litigious a little bit in his talk
about it i'll have to look into it but
didn't actually follow through yeah
which resulted didn't get it shut down
yeah it just resulted in the creator
himself taking it down off his own
accord oh man i wonder
let me consult with the lawyer before we
continue all right i'll hold back on
this if we get approval then we'll play
it till the sun comes up for right now
i'll hold back on this hassan
maybe you can decode this for me you
know scott adams the dilbert guy
who's like a maggot darling the worst
among us hashtag hunted
oh uh i don't know does he think like
does he think that means like you know
conservatives are being hunted yes
is that what he's trying to say i don't
think that because he's tweeted that
before but i don't get what how that
connects to your tweet we were trying to
figure this out
i think he's just like he's being like a
like a hysterical lip but on the other
side where he's like ugh like
you're you're dehumanizing you are
dehumanizing conservatives he just said
trans people should die basically yeah
and he's like yo we're being hunted
nobody
republicans will be hunted oh i see it i
see it yeah how many times democrats try
to jail or otherwise punish republicans
or democrat over democratic hosts
russian collusion january 6 fbi
operation border patrol whipping hoax
feels like a pattern forming hashtag
hunted yeah
that's yeah so he is i'm trying to serve
it as what he's trying to make that
happen he's trying to make hunting
happen
[Laughter]
[ __ ] dilbert i love that
such a mid comic dude i mean he is like
he is demonstrating i mean i'm not gonna
do armchair psychology i don't get
canceled by the foot soldiers but he's
demonstrating a clear pattern of
behavior here that
would lead me to uh
hope that he gets medical treatment
quickly who dilbert or jordan no not
jordan too but uh definitely dilbert
dilbert creator scott adams like yeah
it's a little he he does not seem to be
very healthy uh mentally in a healthy
mental state he's he's you know seeing
patterns pattern recognizing patterns
where no such pattern exists is your is
your tv talking to you uh dilbert guy
are you hearing voices that uh
telling you to do stuff
this could be a sign
yeah of psychosis paranoia you guys
remember this uh tweet thread that he
put up number of times a real gun has
been pointed at my head five what the
[ __ ] have you done in life bro damn bro
number like no i [ __ ] hate how dare
you this dilbert guy is living a
dangerous life
number i've never seen this dan number
of fights i've been in zero i attacked
two bullies in my teen years but they
surrendered without countering what a
badass so cool this dilbert guy's a
tough dude i like that he had to specify
that he has been in fights though but
they just [ __ ] surrender they submit
yeah
like it's zero fights but then again i'm
because i'm a badass click his photo so
you can give context to how badass this
bully killer is
yeah
he's just look man
but this is my favorite one because he's
just talking about how he's constantly a
victim of crime apparently he's had tons
of cars stolen from america let's see
number of times my car stare has been
stolen for a number of times my home or
garage has been burglar five
number of times i've been assaulted at
knife point two so this man has had five
guns and two knives pulled on him
number of times someone stole more than
fifty thousand dollars from me five to
seven seven you can't even remember at
this point it's all your it's your fault
what are you walking around skid row at
three a.m i mean uh what the [ __ ] are
you doing fifty thousand dollars in
unmarked bills
what are you doing how does someone how
does that happen to him no wonder he
thinks everyone's like one thing could
them i mean the man is out walking
around skid row at three yeah first of
all fdic insurance is like for up to 250
000 so what the [ __ ] going on like
what like he
like you can't scam someone and there's
like still fifty thousand dollars from
him with like no way of of getting no
legal recourse unless you quite
literally
got like robbed and you had like a bag
of fifty thousand dollars yeah well he's
talking about street crime right so i'm
assuming that's what he means because if
someone did like white-collar crimes
against him that wouldn't
drum up the crime hysteria he's going
for this right isn't even over he's like
he's been the victim of someone i love
this though i love it he's just like i'm
owned all the time i'm the most owned
man in america like yeah
but right i'm the biggest wait there's
some really good ones in there dan
number of incurable health issues i've
curated myself three oh he you know oh
dude he's one of those piss boys you
know he's doing like the the
the home treatment like drinking his own
urine [ __ ] for sure
oh 100 that's like people that always
say incurable health issues i cured like
they always at some point have
experimented with piss scott adams is a
piss boy this is a good one too number
of full days or vacations no work i have
taken in the past 33 day years five or
so maybe that's why you're losing your
mind dude
maybe it's time to take a vacation i
don't get that flex dude you're you need
to live your life yeah
i don't fight your whole [ __ ] life to
a job is not a virtue man i don't i
don't take days off like i work every
day but i love what i do
it's not a flex you know what i mean
yeah like i'm very fortunate that i
could if i wanted to i could take as
long as a break as i want to
but that's the point right yeah flexing
that on people being just like you don't
work hard enough [ __ ]
it's like well you draw comics dude yeah
i'm a [ __ ] i i scan
inventory at ralph's yeah
he's out here acting like he's doing
hard labor
you know like drawing dilbert comics
yeah
i gotta actually i got a jordan peterson
update uh
what is this this is sounds good
uh a interesting thing though yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] jordan peterson man cowards
and mont bonks what the hell's a mont
bong dude he's really going deep that
was my only uh criticism of your tweet
ethan is you really should have thrown
in like
like rap scallion called him a rap scout
a couple times
a vagabond a montebonk is a person who
deceives others especially in order to
trick them out of their money a
charlatan
so jordan peterson
so yeah this is dennis prager some
[ __ ] pasty pig ass looking [ __ ]
frog race [ __ ] ass loser oh wait is
that dennis prager my favorite author
who uh wrote not one but two famous
articles about how you should be able to
rape your wife yes yes oh that's crazy
um yeah look it up when a woman isn't in
the mood part one and when a woman isn't
in the mood part two uh by dennis prager
imagine writing a whole book about that
how to coerce a partner and you're
having sex seven-time champion of
divorce court how did
wonder how that happened seven times
dennis
yeah that's that's traditional that's
gotta be a williams baby
right talk about family traditions my
dude
anyway this is also a great clip he goes
why the left won't debate even when
offered money this is great dennis
prager says this and then so many people
came out being like i would love to
debate you prominent leftists basically
every single one online was like i would
happily debate you
crickets from from dennis
and uh jordan comes out and again jordan
everyone is willing to debate you're
dumb ass too so yeah what's up like
jordan please come on please come on the
stream [ __ ] you please please please
come on the stream i would love that 100
well this is sort of dennis i'll give
you another interesting thing that
people don't reflect on
we ache to have them on our shows
we ache to debate them shut up but they
won't debate us and they won't come on
our shows and they won't us have us on
their shows
okay dennis you're you're formally
invited
oh i'd love to have dennis prager on
here let's email dennis and then we'll
let's see
would be great like tim poole
we were supposed to debate i'll only
come i'll only debate you if you fly to
my studio during a pandemic yeah and and
give me a little kiss on my beanie i
will pull the beanie off and you will
land a little pucker on my bald spot on
my head and that's the only restrainted
yeah that's the only way that i will uh
have you on the show and if you don't
abide by these conditions that i put up
with
totally unreasonable then uh you're a
coward and you're afraid it's like tim
absolutely all of it
tim
tim poole like i i we talked during the
pandemic and he was like trying to get
me to fly out yeah i was like there's no
shot i'm doing that my mom is living
with me and then he would like every
time i went out once like you know
vaccines came out and stuff every time i
went out he was like well look he's
doing this he's doing that i'm like yeah
[ __ ] like we can zoom like i'm
not trying to be around you bro like
let's just do so annoying and sam cedar
was trying to debate him too he doesn't
want that either it was the height of
the pandemic and he's like you have to
come in my studio and sit he lives in
like florida or some [ __ ] outs place on
the opposite side of the country
and sam's like it's a pandemic i have
kids i'm not i i'm not going to risk
traveling and going into your a studio
with a bunch of people who are
vocally not vaccinated but also like
even if it's not even if it wasn't the
pandemic like i just don't want to take
time out like it's going to take like at
least one to two days of my streaming
schedule
uh to fly to wherever the [ __ ] tim is
right
apparently his studio is like constantly
getting swatted too i don't know why he
keeps admitting that but like i'm not
trying to go there bro like i'm not
trying to [ __ ]
uh you know i don't know i don't want to
hang out with you if we're going to do
it like because he asked originally i
was like yeah of course we can do it in
a way more convenient manner whether
whether it's over zoom or in a location
if he comes to la like i'm fine with uh
debating him somewhere else i guess
not my house though and then i will say
you're a bad person yeah and that's just
a fact so but yeah they they go you have
to do in person it's like dude zoom is
fine [ __ ] so dennis prager jordan
peterson tim paul you're all cordially
invited
so uh we're going to send you uh
official emails inviting you guys onto
our show
so that
we can prove that you're actually
monte blanc yourself [ __ ]
how's the month
monty blanc days dennis prager
here let's watch his pasty [ __ ] idiot
dumbass loser
look at him
he looks like the fat head from rocco's
modern life remember that guy
his neighbor uh ed bighead
yeah let me pull that up
that's important
big head
of course
that's important all right play while
you remember ed bighead that's dennis
prager guys legit
he does
he does have the overall vibes of ed big
100 you guys know you know dollars to
any left-wing
columnist on the new york times to
debate me anywhere they want they could
choose the moderator they could choose
the audience for a second and seriously
i know we're pausing a lot but he said
any leftist columnist at the new york
times brother who's a leftist column at
the [ __ ] new york times you got like
three got elizabeth brunig
uh that's it shouts out to elizabeth
she's like uh one of the few leftist
like actual leftists of the new york
times but other than that like what he's
uh he's out here talking about like
[ __ ] people who defended the iraq war
and [ __ ] who like like thomas friedman
is a leftist in the eyes of dennis
prager
well why also that's pretty niche
uh
category of people to say nobody on the
left will debate me yeah there's plenty
of people on the level with the new york
times bruneg actually left the new york
times she's at the atlantic now oh never
mind don't even have that not even
having there anymore i mean yeah you
have like you have some columnists that
are like you know left adjacent but
there's no like actual evidence of the
new york times like it's not a real
thing
yeah michael
99 of the new york times columnists are
leftist
he disagrees 99
99 of the columns in new york times are
left as he says
well he does well he's like well do you
believe that you should be able to rape
your wife then you're leftist if you if
you don't believe that yeah if you don't
you're obviously wow you're against
spousal rape well must be a leftist jeez
what's next i love those not being able
to f [ __ ] kill ever i'm not gonna go
there
yeah what is th i thought this wasn't
communist china
when a woman isn't in the mood part one
dude this is a longing out it's still up
on his website oh yeah can we get an
e-book of this because i want to no no
it's just it's not it's just two think
pieces that he wrote can you read some
excerpts dan i'm interested i said maybe
please down in the discord uh there's
some really good ones he said a husband
that his wife loves him
first and foremost by her willingness to
give her body to him
you're talking like medieval king
you sound like genghis khan bro a
husband knows that his wife loves him
first and foremost by her willingness to
give her body to him first and foremost
yeah [ __ ] you've been divorced seven
[ __ ] okay
i think it might have been three but oh
it's three but still that's still a lot
yeah actually i don't know it might be
more than three [ __ ]
check that i'm looking up yeah sorry i
didn't want to spread fake news about
that husband knows i got this right i
mean one after the third after the
second one it's like okay you know you
you just this is habitual at this point
you like the divorce court if you get
divorced twice just don't get married
again bro it's all just be just have a
girlfriend a long term like just stop
well
ethan klein leftist agitator does not
want dennis prager to find love
no have love just don't get married it's
not working bro
compared to most women here's another
quote verbatim
compared to most women's sexual nature
men's sexual nature is far closer to
that of an animal so what
that is the way he is made
blame god in nature
i mean he's just literally saying like
he's a rapist
pretty much
he's like
blame god
this is
this is one of the weird types i've seen
in the world is that
people
have this insinuation that women don't
enjoy sex
and
so it's your
duty to take it whenever you want
because she won't be ready
for it and women like sex just not with
you dennis
that's exactly what it is okay i'm gonna
read it first women need to recognize
how a man understands a wife's refusal
to have sex with him a husband knows
that his wife loves him first and
foremost by her willingness to give her
body to him this is rarely the case for
women
few women know their husband loves them
because he gives her his body the idea
sounds almost funny yeah dude it's
because it is it's ridiculous on both
ends yeah
it is but also like yeah obviously no
woman is going to see that as an act of
kindness if that man is get alone just
hanging above them all sweaty
give me your body woman sweat dripping
sweat dripping down his brow he's the
type of dude
not only does he have like
tonsil stones on his lips like ted cruz
when it's time to oh god but you know
when people talk and they start to foam
on the sides of the mouth you know what
i mean oh god he does he gets that he
gets that build up yeah yeah
a kind here's another one a kind woman
who is not sexual with her husband is
not feminine
she is a kind roommate
dude i love that that's so awesome
that's like what a like freshman in
college would say yeah you know yeah bro
like yo your girl she's not [ __ ] you
like she's not a girl she's just a
roommate bro which can't be girls
you know why i i just realized why he
got divorced seven times if they don't
sleep with him in a week he just goes
straight to city hall bro he's just
horny he's just horny that's what it is
he's just like painfully horny sex
republicans are sexy and don't let
anyone tell you different songs look at
ted cruz with the tonsils
oh
my god bro
okay be honest who would you rather [ __ ]
dennis prager or ted cruz i would rather
die no no no
play the game
play the game would i rather [ __ ] dennis
brager at ted cruz
honestly i hate to say it because
they're so both so vile new tech crews
are the beard i think i think ted cruz
is more vile that tonsillitis really did
ted cruz the most
look at that i don't buy a jet no
that man has console stones ready to
launch at you god he's just like so
deformed dude okay we gotta stop we can
we
i i let the record show that i would
rather die in an incredibly
painful manner than about an option
either of these people you gotta suck
one of their dicks i will like i said i
would rather no no even worse than
sucking their dick to be honest you
gotta make out with them
that's both just disgusting like i said
i would i would bite my tongue off
there's another angle of ted cruz with a
tonsil stone on his lip
dude why do you have multiple angles oh
my god they're being fed to me so i have
no choice but to click it
[Music]
oh okay wow
we've made it 30 seconds through this
one minute clip
so let's just [ __ ] finish it and move
on damn
none left
but they would never do it i ache to
debate them i would raise a hundred
thousand dollars probably i could
probably raise that to have tamahindi
or ibram x candy debate larry elder
okay it would end the career of tanahisi
coates or ibrahimovic they know that
they would be regarded as the moral and
intellectual frauds that they are yeah
larry would wipe the floor with them the
key to their success is not enabling us
to have an audience yeah if only there
was like some [ __ ] dumb
idiot on the left who like debated larry
elder
and and thoroughly destroyed him wait
you debate you debated larry what oh my
god that's right i didn't debate larry
said that he would destroy your career
yeah that's so crazy that's so crazy
that that ha that did happen well i am a
[ __ ] idiot apparently because i could
have gotten a hundred thousand dollars
even though yeah it is a little
suspicious that uh it will suppose that
dennis bradger was like only the black
guys
yeah i noticed that yeah that's like
i demand a black on black debate he's
like i have a black champion
you know
i will i will have you fight who's bussy
you eating
69 nice nice
ted cruz is watching this right now
being like
i'm hot as [ __ ] ted cruz is a friend of
the show yeah he's got to suck up to him
because he's going to save us from loot
boxes
i'll be saying
two ted's uh but he is familiar i do
know for a fact that he's familiar with
the house drama uh of mine at the very
least because he has said that
he has talked about it to ted's credit
and it's not much but he does often
engage with people that hate him in a
and uh like he i remember he did like
jimmy kimmel's basketball thing and
he was he's just painfully unlikable
yeah but he he embraces it so it's kind
of dope
oh can you tell me guys is this too much
should i erase this
just tell me real fast yes
it says
he did oh [ __ ]
what did he i was against in the first
place but since it's already up i would
just say you are giving clout to just
some like random weirdo for the right
hand
ethan zero no he is a random weirdo for
sure he's not he's no longer gonna be a
random weirdo now because like the
coalition of [ __ ] haters is gonna
probably be like oh yeah this is a new
champion for us but good
[ __ ] go hang out with keemstar if
that that's your dream this is
alex mandel
he said
by the way we found out that he's like a
keemstar simp which i'm not gonna go
down the rabbit hole it's embarrassing
like just like a month ago he was
tweeting at keemstar being like yo
you're in l.a let's hang out
which explains a lot honestly but i i
i'm not trying to cause beef here or
anything but what i note well i wasn't
until i saw that's not acceptable being
a conservative is one thing but like
you're a keemstar fan bro that's such an
embarrassing thing who's wanting that
roman child like that's a that's an
abortion that should have happened okay
like if you're
how are you gonna [ __ ] act like
you're a fan of keemstar at least say
like oh i i like the drama that he
covers or whatever but like you're gonna
be like i'm a fan of keemstar oh let's
hang out this [ __ ] doesn't have
any fans like he doesn't even have
friends bro like that's what i always
thought and then i was like well anyone
that watches keemstar has to be like a
kid
and i don't think anyone over 18 could
possibly consume this oh he just like
sucks up to like some up-and-coming
content creators to like see if he can
you know get a little bit of their
audience to become like you know drama
fiends for his content while
simultaneously like uh
bashing whoever the [ __ ] he can that
he's declared an enemy right
and
ultimately it's not like a very i mean
it's been a successful business strategy
for him so far but it's not very
successful with him like becoming
uh you know it's not very successful for
him having like any consistent
relationships or friendships i like the
fact that everybody despises them in the
industry straight up i guarantee
keemstar is going to reach out they're
going to be bffs i can't wait for a
keemstar howie
i feel like photo i feel like they
already reached out alex and keem they
made it prior and already coming on yeah
well anyway lindsey graham wasn't going
to say anything we were gonna talk about
ted cruz last thing i always want to say
i always love bringing this up lindsey
graham once said if ted cruz was
murdered on the senate floor you'd find
zero witnesses
that's awesome lindsey graham said that
yeah lindsey graham himself is not
exactly the most the bell of the ball or
popular in general
so i just i need to answer on this guys
so i wasn't going to say anything i was
like fine he's a keemstar stan it makes
total sense
but i saw on this someone sent this or i
saw it on the server or something
someone said hey you had a blah blah
blah you had ethan on why'd you have to
do that whatever
and then he responded how does ethan's
dick taste
and i was like hell nah bro
so iris you know 15 likes yeah oh my god
well it had zero when i saw it
to be told exactly it and it would have
stayed at zero if you just ignored it
honestly that's a perfect example of how
this works and i do this all the [ __ ]
time too i can't stop myself but like
this is how you breathe air because you
have you breathe air into your [ __ ]
haters and and this is how they gain
clout i'm fine with him having clout
alex have the clout
you know no but i can't wait for him to
hang out with keemstar i think that'll
be great for for everybody
but he i says well you took it pretty
deep on monday you tell me
so should i remove it can we do a poll
i would i mean if you delete it now then
people are gonna be like oh you coward
you deleted it because you were afraid
or some [ __ ] oh wait let me read his
response because maybe it's nice and
then i will feel bad there's more he has
five tweets about it on this oh [ __ ]
okay let's just sorry sorry to pull you
into this song i just need to i don't
know what to do
chet said alex is how he's checked
i don't totally
how dare how dare chad say that chet
hanks at least like
chet has [ __ ] no
at least like chad hanks whether
oblivious or aware is an entertaining
figure
yeah
shout out to the island [ __ ] alex
mendelman
that's actually pretty good thank you
it's like surprise
why are you good at that
shout out to the island we've been
talking about chet for like two years
ago so weird because like you're
not good obviously but like your chat
was i'm bad yeah i'm bad at impressions
but i'm glad to hear that that one
that's one that actually is solid alex
mandel pussycloth
[Laughter]
i'm not the one filled with hate here i
can i can like keemstar and ethan at the
same time i was excited for ethan to
come on hope you guys can find something
more accurate and meaningful to spend
your time on
all right let me let me can you send me
the thread because i i don't know
everything's all confusing bro wait
he [ __ ] responded to keemstar oh
keemstar is definitely going to hit him
up now
he hit up keemstar says you're in l.a
and then got and then got [ __ ]
ignored by him
damn bro keemstar was like sorry but i'm
gonna hang out with some 14 year olds
actually instead of you because they
have tick-tock clout
damn hassan
wants bad stuff to happen to black
people god damn it i love that
so good so he said he'd been hitting up
kim for a while i'm not the oh this he
responded to this tweet his original one
asking him if he's in la
he said i'm not the one filled with hate
here i can like keem and ethan at the
same time i was excited for he didn't
come on hope you guys can find something
more accurate and meaningful to spend
your time on okay fair enough can you
like game anything at the same time
maybe no not really not really can't
like team that's the whole part like i'm
not right i don't care you like whoever
the [ __ ] you want but like
when you say you enjoy keemstar's
content that's a self-report like you
should keep that you should keep that a
secret like you should be embarrassed to
admit well it's obvious the thing to me
that kind of blew my mind is in the
interview
i was like this is some fallen fan
questions and obviously it was him that
loaded them up
and finding out he's a keemstar fan
really connects the dots
uh
someone said bro screenshots of
keemstar's timeline is not notes if you
want to pretend to have a brain try not
to regurgitate his exact points uh he
didn't show them a single keemstar he
did pull up at keemstar's tweet uh
during the show i said bring up the clip
of me saying b b word and that's the one
he used and he pulled up i said full i
said get a clip of it in the whole
context and this dude pulled up
keemstar's tweet
being like ethan's domestic terrorist
content yeah all the context
he said huh i didn't show them a single
keemstar tweet there's a girl who runs
the content research for what they see
on the podcast and she doesn't even know
who keemstar is okay
fair enough
there it is
so should i erase it what do you guys
think
i'm i don't know
do you it's already done it's already
done you shouldn't have done it in the
first place i i just after everything
that happened and then finding out i was
a keemstar stan and then being like how
does ethan's dick taste and everybody
enjoyed the show it was fine no i know
it was fine you're right it was totally
fine yeah
i can't no not everything is fine he
[ __ ] bleep my name what the [ __ ]
that oh that is weird as [ __ ] that's
weird as hell bro what are you doing
he did it for hassan that's what it was
all about
and he bleeped trump
yeah you guys are on the same level
apparently yeah
it's messed up
well so i think i don't know what
happened but i said
so there was a point i was saying
everything that i could to offend howie
and i kept saying be the nra a bunch of
times
and i was just trying to think of
controversial things to say
so at one point i said oh you should
hear what my co-host said he said
uh dan crenshaw got skull [ __ ] and i i
i've watched that part yeah yeah so
i it was totally fine right but i in
retrospect i was like i don't want i
don't want it to seem like i'm throwing
hassan under the bus
so i texted howie and said can you
please remove that part
where i said where i was talking about
my co-host no i don't give a [ __ ] well
anyway i think what they did is bleeped
your name and kept it in oh nobody will
be able to figure out who you are
well no they they also didn't censor
after because you bring my name up again
and they didn't censor the second time
yeah okay that at least makes sense now
like it doesn't really because that was
one
can you remove that part please because
i don't want it to seem like you know
i'm throwing my buddy under the bus i
just i wasn't sure how who would play
it came out fine
but but yeah
he was very offended by that that was it
was cool to see him like get
you know flail around a little bit like
what oh dude that's that's not woke how
was that woke
it's not work i was like i'm not woke
[ __ ] i mean
i'm not who said anything about woke but
you know the truth is
it did go fine but honestly they
because of the line of questions and how
they presented they it was a they tried
to do a gotcha it ended up good i don't
think howie and his sister knew what was
happening there was just my daughter
yeah
his his what how his daughter what is
this what'd i say
what's wrong with me dude my brain
you're thinking about it don't work so
good alex's sister my brain don't work
so yeah alex's sister but i don't know
and it's just kind of i was like man
what the [ __ ] it's good to see you
outside of the podcast your own well
nobody else never gonna invite me on the
show again after this
that's not true i'm i'm sure plenty of
people would still love to do that
has
10 times the views of any other episode
oh yeah yeah well to be honest i i do
get i do get invited on people's shows
but i don't like doing other people's
shows i know it was a rare you know
my show i've asked you to come on i do i
will come on your show it's just i don't
know it's like it's so hard it's so hard
to commit to stuff man i just i honestly
like i have a wedding to go to
this weekend and it's ruining my whole
month just oh i know i know what that's
like though and it's just you know i
just putting making plans is just the
bane of my existence i agree yeah
100 i'm i'm the same they're a little
boy like as long as as long as i have my
structure my regimen i'm fine but the
moment that i uh the moment that like
something throws it off which by the way
i'm gonna be going uh i i'll be going to
europe
so is that right yeah on the week of uh
14th i'm not gonna be able to do the
leftovers podcast july yeah in july are
you just taking a vacation no no it's
just for work but what's twitchcon just
running you in amsterdam
twitchcon
yeah in amsterdam oh she's planning on
going to potentially going to uh you
know oybrov land before beforehand to
the uk
hang out with some people there some
content creators there nice man good
that's great
yeah that'll be fun we'll see but it but
it's but i'm in the same boat where i'm
like oh my irl backpack is not working
that's a big one work like yeah that's
how am i gonna how am i gonna have like
a consistent streaming schedule like
those are all things that are just like
weighing on my consciousness right now
every single moment
yes
with your irl backpack um
i know a thing or two about those i
could probably fix it for you yeah i
just
that's a good offer he's really good
with that stuff all right well i'll i'll
take it i mean i i need i need help on
that right now for sure you're gonna
need european sim cards and stuff too
yeah cool things that's that's the
problem yeah you got to figure that
stuff out but yeah i mean having having
the howie podcast
coming up it was just ruined my whole
[ __ ] week i was like god damn i have
to do this podcast on friday like [ __ ] i
know i was all weak jokingly i was
saying to elis don't take it seriously
but i've been like [ __ ] howie mandel in
a stupid [ __ ] podcast all week
because i was just like so annoyed i
thought you're gonna bail
for sure you did yeah 100
no
well i'm glad you didn't bail yeah
that's funny no no no i wasn't going to
build but um anyway can we do a pull
should i just embrace this i don't know
or
it's just i'll erase it i'll i'll back
it up i don't know
just do a pull you already posted it who
cares i i kind of i was the main person
telling you not to post it but now that
it's out there i don't know what it's
also like not the worst thing who cares
yeah and howie i apologize you know i i
i did you apologize for throat [ __ ]
his son i didn't [ __ ]
i apologize for coming your pockets and
then having sexual intercourse with your
throat i'm so sorry
nothing personal
but the good news well the good news is
for alex is that he's probably going to
finally meet his idol keemstar probably
and they're probably going to be besties
and like i said i can't wait for
keemstar to come on the podcast and i
can't wait for a selfie with howie
keemstar and alex that's going to be
happening we're going to frame that
i really can't wait what i i'd love to
see what he talks about he's starting to
pay your royalties he's keeping his
career yes absolutely to be honest
that's totally true man and i like and i
and i like to do that for him yeah
oh no i thought you i thought you came
to your conclusion all right no i'm wait
i i need to people
delete the tweet
i need the people's approval
okay um while you figure that out i'm
gonna go pee and then after that let's
get to the rhino hunting okay all right
cause that one's really good my god
we're not getting through anything today
by the way we're an hour into the show
we've done
one thing from the doc we're having fun
we watched one one minute clip
one item
which is fine it's fine oh wow okay 85
86 percent say no so the people
have spoken to people 30 oh and
it is pretty funny i was against it too
but that's the thing is like yeah it
made some people here laugh and i was
like well that that's pretty good yeah
that's rare bad influences in this
office yeah and then eli yelled at me
though when she saw it which of course
she said predictable
she said ethan
you need to have some class sometimes
yes there you go and evil if you're
watching
she said she said who cares if his son
is a douche
yes
she gets it it's not funny me and dan
were against it that's it not call
anyone out but me and i'm not i don't
want to say who i don't want to name
names but there was several people here
people and it's in the studio that
supported me i'm starting to realize
there's a certain there's a certain set
yep in this office
that are they're the little devils on
ethan's shoulder oh actually can i say
the names can i say the names of my
supporters it was me so it was olivia
cam and zach were like do it yeah
awesome and olivia's the one actually
that tilted me up because
you know okay
cam is the one that surprises me olivia
and zach i get olivia wanted to sue
havoc
i guess
[Laughter]
i like the drama of it all
okay but guys i i do i actually here let
let me say this
in my defense i was just grumpy this
morning
that was just a grumpy little i just
thought it was [ __ ] quick witty and
funny i don't know thanks bro and that
too i'm sorry ela i apologize
well i know better than to listen to you
but olivia's
we've learned that lesson over the years
wait so let me just do my due diligence
and just say for the record i can't
what's how do you spell men mandel like
that here it is why is there a [ __ ]
random harry styles in the bathroom
right
out of me this morning what the [ __ ] i
walked into me and almost pissed my
pants
harry styles is just popping out dude
he's just hanging out they keep moving
it whoever's doing it keeps moving it
can somebody olivia can you go take a
picture of what it looks like when you
walk into the bathroom i want to show
the audience what what we're talking
about here
it's also the
it's also the [ __ ] uh the the
nightclub bathroom one yeah yeah yeah
yeah olivia's body bathroom
that was the episode that got removed
when we unveiled the party bathroom when
we got home
yeah
so just to just to do my due diligence
here and give alex a fair shake he said
currently getting a horde of h3 fans
tweeting me with some assumptions i
don't like him i like him ethan i talked
after the podcast even making him aware
i've never seen any leafy's content no
drama between us at all
don't make some up okay
he's right there's no drama between us
that's except for this drama
don't don't harass alex it's all good
it's fine don't don't you know
i mean
well am i crazy
i didn't misinterpret the
house ethan's dick taste comment right
because no i think he's yeah that was
advocating yeah that was a little
aggressive yeah for sure okay but
yeah okay but don't don't harass them
guys leave the mandels alone they're
good people
[ __ ] god
pick up [ __ ] forever man
can you say alex mendel again in that
voice alex mandel chetna forever
psych tom hanks
[Laughter]
we 100 could have chet on by the way no
chet hates me oh yeah oh he hates you
yeah he didn't hate me we've dm before
oh well maybe you can mend the bridge
because we wanted to have him on and uh
yeah he dm'd ethan like
[ __ ] you you fat [ __ ] or something it
was actually kind of weird because i had
andrew santino on and we were talking
about chat it wasn't really that bad we
were just doing our andrew does an
incredible
chet impression
and andrew's a really nice guy he really
is and chet send and andrew is the
angel's the ginger yeah uh dude right
yeah he's funny as hell i like people
too a good dude yeah i like it so chet
sent
andrew out of the blue a really
threatening like straight-up aggressive
threatening message yeah
i don't remember what it was exactly and
then he also dm me like you fat [ __ ] i
hope i don't keep that energy if i see
you in person
is he going to fight you that'd be funny
that's what it sounds about i mean he's
a big dude no i don't want to fight chet
yeah jet will stop me he told andrew i
look forward to running into you one day
oh yeah just straight aggressive like in
the mean streets of [ __ ] beverly glen
baby
why is he acting like he's just so tough
oh jesus i hope i don't run into you on
venice beach man i'd be spending my days
yeah on my on my like multi-million
dollar [ __ ] you know penthouse in in
venice
yeah that'd be real scary if i saw you
so anyway
he
basically threatened us with violence
and then
i could think it all went downhill from
there
chat is joker brand
full four i found it oh we have the dm
oh you said that to santino yeah i look
forward to running into you one day tell
me that you have a sense of humor enjoy
the satire of the impression nah to tell
you that is going to be hilarious not
just not for you
you do understand the comedy right
i thought he sent him some weight
threatening why did he [ __ ] post
these dm's that make him look better oh
it was andrew and then he erased them
real fast i thought i thought andrew
posted them he did oh he did he did
andrew posted them and then he was like
um we shouldn't [ __ ] with him he seems
unstable
yeah okay
i just but yeah andrea andrew posted
them and erased it
pretty crazy one of the chess said
weezer's beverly hills is his hood
anthem
true
chet chetan uh i mean his old music chet
and alex are probably uh neighbors
we come from the hot streets of malibu
yeah don't [ __ ] with us
he's he's a very he's a wonderful
character
he's
fun anyway i'm i'm sorry mandel family i
wish you nothing but the best you got
listen you guys did a no deal deal or no
deal with me and my case had a big fat
zero in it so i'm sorry you guys just
pulled the wrong case
you thought you were going to get a
million votes this is one of those news
where i have no idea what you're
referencing
deal no deal that's how he's big don't
know what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i've no
idea it was a game show that was on like
deal no deal
did you open the briefcase bro i grew up
in turkey i don't [ __ ] know no
it just happened a couple years ago oh
is this still there pull up a picture it
was a while ago was it i've never i've
also never had cable so like i've been
living in america since 2009 and i've
never had cable so i don't want like i
don't see any of these tv shows i
thought that was a big deal unless
they're like super old tv shows that are
that we're resurfacing to watch to make
fun of i mean it i think the last
episode was like a decade ago oh is that
right yeah it was two no oh my god look
at that savage [ __ ] beard bro what
does he have the triangle i forgot he
had that wicked oh my god wait why is he
like a does he ride like a like a hog
well this was this was like mid 2000s i
want to say i don't think that soul
patch was ever accepted 2005.
yeah there is no time period when that
was like an appropriate thing to have on
your face i love the fred durst look
right that's true did it all for the
nookie go to the top left i love this
charlie's angel vibes of this
looks like maybe the the
beard was short-lived because
anyway
no deal was like a generation defining
game show i mean it was a big deal
2005 is when it started damn okay i'm
old as [ __ ] yep
yeah i wasn't i wasn't in the country
back then is that right you weren't here
in 2000 no i was in the mean streets of
turkey ankara
when did you move here 2009.
so you've only came to miami
oh you landed in miami yeah
how was that [ __ ]
it's
it's kind of weird there i don't know
how to describe it it's just like
everything you see out of florida like
you know how a friend of the show andrew
does a lot of great you know videos like
channel five just recently the daytona
uh daytona bike rally thing like
florida is like that
across the board it's just like in a
stasis period like
enter
you enter the barrier of florida and all
of a sudden you're just like time slows
down
uh you behave in an erratic way
like an insane way and every part of
florida is like that
from gainesville
tampa
to you know panama city uh panama city
beach all the way down to miami it's
just like varying degrees of it it's
like a different flavor in every
different part of florida but it's the
same like weird
uh you know time slowed down you're
doing crazy [ __ ] attitude
i went i've been to florida once to meet
dj khaled
i did not like it very much i mean i
thought orlando was really fun with all
the theme parks but outside of the theme
parks it's pretty [ __ ] nuts around
there
another one no florida is florida's pvp
unlocked we went to the waffle house it
was a little dicey there
florida is always easy florida's always
pvp unlocked i mean speaking of which
like there was a there was a state
legislature that got [ __ ] murked by a
dude and a prius like after uh after
like a like a you know car crash
he got out of his car and shot it like
some dude in a prius and the dude in the
prius dipped out from the from the
passenger seat in the front
hid behind the engine block got up one
tap the florida legislation oh my god
dead wait wait a legislator got in a
gunfight
yeah bro this happened like a couple
months ago wait wait what yeah i mean
that that that is a florida story but
whoa
by the way waffle house the food was
bomb as [ __ ] though i gotta be straight
up it was a little dicey dicey but the
food was great oh yeah the dice is
satisfied yeah it's really good though
it was so good that was the thing i was
like damn
wait let me see maybe it wasn't a
legislator but he was like a gop rep
gop representative they were a house rep
he got in a gun fight with a priest
owner this is [ __ ] sick yeah florida
state board of administration official
killed an apparent road rage road rage
shootout okay yeah and he had gotten
into another like road rage incident at
the same exact spot he's 52 years old
spot what did you just camp out there
and shoot it past him like on his way
home he's just getting [ __ ] angry and
and doing like road rage [ __ ]
uh and you know they pull over following
a collision okay
he like tries to block the dude from
leaving with his car
uh the driver of the priest confronted
ku kuzwanski and then got back into his
car to wait for law enforcement to
investigate the accident the exchange
then escalated dramatically as kuzwanski
rammed his bmw into the prius on the
driver's door began pushing the car
sideways in the parking lot damn typical
bmw drivers by the way holy [ __ ] dude
it's just like universal i swear to god
kozwanski then shot a gun at the white
prius okay he's probably like yeah this
[ __ ] lip toward and then the priest
driver who also had a gun shot and fired
back in the kuzwanski's windshield
striking him
shot did he kill him yeah he slid dude
he see yo exactly
[ __ ]
chicken dinner or what did he say yeah
dinner yeah exactly boom
done dead it's crazy straight up good
old western shootout yeah he's a driller
straight up
[ __ ] incredible incredibly precise
respect respect to the prius driver we
don't know who he is but
you know he's a real one
probably like an accountant by the way
because that's [ __ ] florida you could
like literally be like i'm the
comptroller and then like you have uh
you know an sks or something you just
like [ __ ] pull out
yeah florida's a weird place the weather
was i kind of enjoy the weather though
the tropical
stormy weather but so how long were you
in miami tell you for a year and then
you came to and i went to rutgers and
then uh and then i needed to get the
[ __ ] out of new jersey i was like this
sucks oh you went from miami to new
jersey yeah and then i moved to la and
i've been living here ever since
so la do you like la comparative i love
it yeah compared to what
miami
yes
i love l.a you know but but but i'm not
that worldly i mean i've only lived in
israel and new york
i personally love la and santa cruz it's
fairly world no i think i think i love
los angeles uh it's got a lot of good
and it's got a lot of bad but you know i
i love living here
um especially the weather you just can't
beat it
that's like the main reason even though
i never leave my house i just like the
overall vibes this is nice you you
really take it for granted when you go
somewhere else and you're like whoa it's
cold or not sunny every [ __ ] day in
perfect weather like what is this
but there you have it so where are we
jordan peterson and drag of course we're
going to talk about we're going to talk
about some drillers you know
if this man hates
if this man hates drag so much then
explain this
sorry yeah it's okay when he does it
remember how we talked about with
madison cawthorne like straight dudes
love being homoerotic with other people
that they perceive to be straight as
well like in a comfortable environment
especially if it's like to belittle uh
you know other straight men by doing
like gay acts on them right this is a
this is like in line with that principle
of like it's okay if jordan peterson
does it it's just not okay if someone
who was like
we're presenting doing it you know what
i mean because then it's then it's
indeed serious
how absurd yeah what's the context of
drag peterson
uh his daughter posted this photo i
believe uh i think they were just
[ __ ] around i let her have her way oh
no oh
my god no no keep going keep going oh no
no no what else did she do to you i saw
my maternal grandmother sitting by the
bank of a swimming pool there we go
which was also a river
the genital region was exposed dimly it
had the appearance of a thick matter
this is the worst thing
mindedly
she walked over to me with a handful of
pubic hair compacted into something
resembling a large artist's paintbrush
she pushed i told ethan last night this
is what he should have replied
to
jordan's uh tweet with oh god i let her
only rewind raised my arm several times
to deflect her hand
finally i'm willing to hurt her or
interfere with her any further i just i
let her have her way
my emotions
were like a paintbrush she stroked it on
my face i let her have her way a dilf
jordan you're such a [ __ ]
cartoon character yes all right what do
you want to talk about
we can look we can we can do a quick
rhino hunting game because that guy is
like [ __ ] insane yes yes and then
immediately move on to the main story of
the day because like that one is really
good so wait we've got the rhino hunter
and then what's the the one you like
here okay yeah that's good all right so
this is a new ad and there's basically
conservatives are an arm race for who's
the most [ __ ] crazy this guy's
apparently a former navy seal
and oh this tweet was removed by twitter
this tweet violates the twitter rules
about abusive behavior yeah however
twitter has determined that it may be in
the public's interest for the tweet to
remain and i can't even see it because
like i'm not logged into twitter so for
for me because i'm not logged into
twitter it says age-restricted adult
content
yeah so you can you can quote tweet it
it looks like you can't copy the link
like you have to go to the url but you
can do that on twitter yeah so get a
load of this [ __ ] lunatic um
this is like a badge of honor to be so
crazy that twitter bans you they're like
yeah dude here watch this [ __ ] i'm eric
greitens navy seal and today we're going
rhino hunting
the rhino feeds on corruption and is
marked by the stripes of cowardice
[Music]
join the maggot crew get a rhino hunting
permit there's no bagging limit no
tagging limit and it doesn't expire
until we save our country hell yeah he's
gonna murder republicans like he's like
i'm going to use my weapons to murder
republicans is what he's saying so rhino
if you don't know is republican in name
only they use it as a derogatory for
anyone that doesn't toe the trump line
perfectly and i just find it so
interesting that not like he was like
we'll get to the democrats later first
we got to weed out these traitors yeah
no i love that it's like anarchists on
[ __ ] twitter who constantly are like
trying to left-check people and be like
oh like wreckers you know what i mean
people who just routinely be like you're
not left enough you bought a house okay
like i like the republican version of
that let them fight it's cool it's i
love i love infighting that is kind of
what's happening there yeah i mean
marjorie taylor green's been out being
like they're all [ __ ] traitors yeah
dude because uh yeah the j6 stuff like
you know they're not defending the brave
american patriots and i think that
marjorie taylor green is right margarine
taylor green titan
so eric greitens is the uh you might be
shocked uh if you are unfamiliar with
american politics
but uh
eric himself was uh in a position of
prominence it's not like he is
he's been a senator dude no he's running
for senate in missouri but no he was not
he was not a senator before he was the
governor oh this man was the governor
okay
eric groper
or gropins okay uh was the governor
and uh at the time
uh he he had to resign because they had
enough votes to impeach him already
um
he uh
he he there's like a
a bunch of incredible information came
out
about him originally
that he
had sexual intercourse uh or raped
groped assaulted
binded with ropes
a uh a woman
binded with a group photos of yeah and
that he was actually
not his wife not his wife his wife the
wife thing is uh new or not new but like
additional information so who who was
this person he he bound and and our word
and why wasn't he arrested
because missouri is the governor yes
when he was the governor he hit
groped and coerced the woman into sexual
contact and then said if you come out
with this i will show everyone the the
footage that i took of you like photos
that i took right yeah so he did like
revenge porn too
a law that he actually signed into law
in missouri uh making it like illegal
and severe give severe punishments to if
you do uh revenge porn
surprise um he passed that bill yeah and
the republican house of representatives
in missouri actually
thought that this was compelling enough
to impeach him
there were enough votes for him to get
impeached so he resigned the day of his
uh impeachment vote um but yeah the
testimony included uh
you know her being locked in a basement
and and bound with ropes
and and naked as he took photos he i was
a navy seal boy
you could trust me
yeah
now it doesn't end there of course uh
then his ex-wife came out and said that
he
not only beat was a perfect husband but
also beat their child their
three-year-old child he like grabbed the
three-year-old child by the hair
swung him around you know did a bunch of
insane [ __ ]
i'm just gonna read you
uh the former wife's affidavit this is
from southpaw okay
okay um eric's behavior included threats
in order to coerce me or to do so uh
from or or to do or to refrain from
doing and saying certain things after
eric admitted to me in late january 2021
that he had taken the photo that
resulted in the invasion of privacy
charge he threatened that i would be
exposed to legal jeopardy if i ever
disclose that act to any that fact to
anyone even family members or a
therapist because of the reach of his
influence in missouri i believed him
which had the consequence of isolating
me from many sources outside of support
as his threats escalated and my concerns
grew for my safety and that of my
children
this is from his former right is this
guy leading right now to be a senator
sure is oh my god oh yeah [ __ ] god
this guy is like a dexter victim
you know like what the [ __ ] he has uh
wonderful campaign ads like where he
usually shoots a a minigun like who
would have thought that the guy
threatening to kill fellow republicans
for not being extreme enough beats his
son and wife and rapes people eric eric
greitens is such a [ __ ] psychotic
freak that his wife actually found
solace and comfort by escaping to texas
when you [ __ ] escape to texas dude
like
that's how you know shit's really [ __ ]
up in missouri okay this guy's gonna be
there he beat not only her
uh and also uh threatened with a gun not
only his ex-wife but also their children
um so mark my words he's gonna be
president by the end of the decade guys
yeah trump's like that's nothing i
r-ordered 30 women and i'm still
president
so he's leading the polls this is a
great guy to add to the senate the best
the best the best of us so okay there
you go
let's move on to
our favorite topic of the day which is
of course light year
pixar's new film about
a buzz lightyear
he's got his own feature of toy story
apparently conservatives are
loving the fact that this video
movie
didn't do great in the box office it
didn't do bad though either but yeah it
did kind of bad
for a toy story movie or like something
in the toy store i don't know what it is
i'm gonna be like interested at all and
watch it because it looks dumb yeah it's
like buzz i don't know because it's got
lesbians in it brother that's why we're
not watching it so every conservative
every single one of them
had a moral panic
because
two women kiss in this film
and i wait till you see the let me show
you the clip it's gotta be his clip is
so funny he's got like so gratuitous let
me show you this tom brady would be like
you're not kissing me hard enough
because john kissed them this this
gently okay
this is important context so you can see
what all this uh mania is about so here
it is
here it is
that's it
that's the whole thing that's [ __ ]
dude you didn't offer a trigger warning
brother what the [ __ ]
i'm gay now
[Laughter]
i saw that i want to do homosexual acts
[Laughter]
so let's see what ben shapiro's
perfectly measured take on this is
disney works to push a not at all secret
gay agenda and seeks to add queerness to
its programming according to executive
producer latoya ravanu parents should
keep that in mind before deciding
whether to take their kids to see
lightyear which hits theaters this week
what is a gay agenda like i don't know
what he means does he think that
disney's trying to turn people gay is
that what that means
yes the gay agenda is why would they do
that the gay agenda is just uh diversity
like uh representation initiatives that
of course um capitalist corporations
engage in because uh newsflash this
might come as a shock to all the
conservatives in the audience but like
gay people do exist and they buy stuff
they buy products
also i mean disney is all notoriously
always been gay as hell so i don't know
why the [ __ ] they're like super pissed
off about like overt
queerness in their programming i saw
that peck
um
but
basically he's saying children are not
adults what may be appropriate for
adults is not appropriate for children
that this must be said demonstrates that
our society is in a state of moral
collapse why because a lesbian couple an
interracial right oh
uh
i didn't even notice dude
so yeah you guys are not up to date on
your on your conservative uh brain rot
you know so
they're they're basically saying like if
you show this happened in arthur like uh
alabama pbs actually banned arthur from
showing there was because there was a
gay marriage episode on our
dance yeah
and uh the idea is that like they just
want to keep grooming their children
into uh thinking that like gay people
don't exist so if they do have god
forbid like a gay child a queer child um
then uh you know the kid will want to
kill themselves because uh they can't
come out and they can't feel like they
what you know their feelings are valid
and that they're acceptable
um and that's that's the agenda the
agenda is to not make children feel that
poorly about themselves and to show them
that like no you can be
a normal human being uh in a civilized
society you know that's a really good
point if you are
a young kid who's confused about his
sexuality he might be gay
uh seeing that actually could probably
go a long way to helping kids come out
of the closet and exist in our
that's exactly what they're terrified of
though they're like no it should be we
should continue bullying queer people
they should live in fear yeah no that's
that's exactly the point and so they say
that we play the song and
dance how can you say
this is
i mean this is just so vile this is the
moral collapse of our state
like
dude what the [ __ ] bro
you are such a piece of [ __ ]
yeah you are such a [ __ ]
i think like uh easy oh [ __ ]
the the other part of this is that you
know the the kiss scene is like
ridiculous it's not a big deal it opened
a 50 million dollar weekend far short of
disney's hope 70 to 85 million that's
what the notes say and that
um you know part of it was because there
was a lot of controversy around it is
what they're saying but like usually
that kind of controversy actually
factors in to the marketing
um i think companies benefit from that
because then you see like pushback from
the liberal side that then go and
consume the content you know what i
think is like we're all [ __ ] drones
at this point
um
ultimately uh i think it was banned in
in 14 countries yep buzz here yeah like
the
great countries such as saudi arabia
stuff like that yeah our allies
our important allies such moral
authorities as saudi arabia yes yeah um
let's see yeah the buzz lightyear kiss
was united arab emirates probably let's
see yeah united arab emirates it was
banned
um malaysia i'll tell you where it was
banned yeah
where the [ __ ] why doesn't this article
he wants to join the list
of countries banning
yeah nations included are bahrain egypt
indonesia iraq jordan kuwait lebanon
saudi arabia syria and uae what what's
in what's what's in the common
denominator with all those countries the
common denominator in all those
countries is that as a consequence of
american and western involvement
destroying their uh you know societies
they have incredibly reactionary
incredibly fundamentalist conservative
oftentimes american state-backed
leadership in all of these countries
that promote these sorts of
fundamentalist conservative values these
are
does ben like uh islamic people
ben hates the i i say this all the time
on my stream but like one of the
funniest things about conservatives that
they [ __ ] hate
other conservatives for their
conservatism right
he wants to be one so bad or not enough
but like one of these
extremist ones there's no there's
conservatives no difference between ben
shapiro that's why jordan peterson for
example is very popular in in in muslim
countries i don't know if you guys knew
this or not but yeah ab always says that
in his hometown yeah everybody he's like
super popular there yeah um yeah that's
so interesting so
functionally there's no difference
between like uh like a wahhabist and and
ben i mean he's an ultraducks uh
ultra conservative a jewish person right
that wants to live by that that dogma
so there's no difference the only main
difference is that america is a
judeo-christian nation right like that's
the only difference is that his
conservatism is considered good and
palatable whereas that exact same kind
of conservatism overseas is seen as like
barbaric which i do think is barbaric
but it's barbaric here as well yeah just
as barbaric interesting eh
what's this here if disney insists on
opposing bills the ban sexual
indoctrination of kindergarteners i love
that just
dude you're so [ __ ] don't go see
lightyear and if gillette says true
masculinity is teaching her daughter to
shave her face
get your razors elsewhere okay these
kinds of initiatives are going to fail
though this is basically the other side
of that exact same equation look back in
the early 2000s they used to have like
you know doctor diet or
dr pepper 10 it's for boys you know what
i mean remember that sort of stuff like
there was always marketing initiatives
that was like about hyper masculinity
and capturing that these are
corporations they're not people they
only care about uh you know boosting
profits they only care about improving
shareholder value increasing shareholder
value so they're going to do whatever
they can and right now we're in an era
for the past like 10 15 years where
there's like over correction happening
on the corporate side
that that
creates this air of wokeness i guess
where corporations act like they care
brands act like they care about social
justice initiatives social justice
causes but it's just for marketing it's
just i'd rather they pretend to care
though than than not yeah and like like
now you're seeing this now you're seeing
ben shapiro and the likes of ben shapiro
and others do the exact same thing that
like gillette is doing when they say
[ __ ] toxic masculinity but in the other
direction and it's a failure because at
the very least like gillette has
billions of uh
dollars put into marketing initiatives
on top of that you know they've like
already monopolized a certain part of
the market like you're not going to be
able to get in with jeremy's razors and
like try to tackle that by
by being like yeah we're we're selling
razors but only for non-woke people
as bad faith as like um
a lot of these companies who put like
pride flags and stuff on their logos
as much as they're just doing it for
profit of incentive i do think
it's better than not because i mean just
making that more accepted culturally is
you know
yeah i mean they're doing it for cover
though like they're doing it for sales
and they're also doing it for cover when
they shield their other like actual
nefarious actions like funding anti-gay
politicians you know what i mean you see
it all the time all these companies i
did a video on this where like pride
month corporations
uh and like what their prime initiatives
are
versus like how much money they've given
to uh
the anti-lgbt yeah that's interesting
political movements
and that's how it works walmart will
throw up the blackfish and say black
lives matter while simultaneously
funding a police state that is the cause
of the problem
uh and also funding politicians that
that continue a lack of accountability
in policing that allows police to keep
murdering black people unarmed black
people
at
incredibly disproportionate rates in
comparison to any other race so
it's a it's a systemic problem uh all of
this is just like seasoning i get what
you're saying though i do understand it
like it makes it feel like it's better
it's better than not
you know yeah but it's just not
it's a it's not the end all be all uh no
no not at all it's just that it just
adds a little extra vibe which is good i
think
yeah but guess who else was part of this
moral panic jordan peterson maybe disney
and pixar could concentrate on telling a
story instead of distributing propaganda
to children that room would remind you
again that scene was two seconds long
it's a peck
nothing
yes but they're not they're not wrong
like as far as anyone that says like
these mega corporations need to stop
recycling ip and like actually make new
and compelling and unique that's not
what he said but that's not what he's
saying i know it's just like i i do
agree i agree with that but that's not
what he said well that's so annoying
like make good movies i don't care if
they're bad figures in there i don't
care if they're showcasing like even
homophobia especially because like
in almost all of those circumstances
they're showing in a negative light
regardless you know what i mean as long
as it's a good movie you know as long as
it's compelling it's new it's unique and
it's not just like recycling
that's the whole industry been like that
for decades yeah
jordan is talking about a two second
clip
of a peck
and he's reduced the whole film to
propaganda for children i mean dude
you're mentally ill jordan you you
really
have fallen so far yes yes
talking about your grandma's pubes and
[ __ ] you're delirious yeah
i have more um
here's some more
this is from the great
oh yeah the go won't go broke stuff i
mean it's so stupid
plenty of woke films have made money
like wouldn't you say like get out was a
woke film and that was like gangbusters
so that whole go woke get broke thing is
so [ __ ] dumb yeah and i'm sorry
there's nothing broke about it to woke
about a two second peck you [ __ ]
yeah i think like the controversy
surrounding this has less to do with
like its box office performance maybe
like the international box office if
they were banned from multiple countries
like 14 of them that i just read um but
ultimately i i think like
people don't care to do it like people
just don't give a [ __ ] about buzz
lightyear like no one wanted to see sexy
buzz lightyear
right
which also he's a toy why why what are
we back in like boot camp because yeah
they were saying like this is the
character story behind like the actual
person nobody is the real
man that the toy was based off of in
the universe of toy story which is just
such a [ __ ] convoluted weird ass
premise for a movie that of course it
wasn't going to do well
yeah
um it's silly there you have it there's
a one other thing i want to talk about
is
what's your thoughts on this so you guys
know that there's the uh
commission right now for january 6
and there's a huge breaking story
that apparently there was a
documentarian crew
with trump and his team
during the time
when he was working to
allegedly overthrow the election
there's hours on that day on january 6
where all the phone records were erased
and this crew was apparently there
filming this whole time and the and the
um committee has subpoenaed them to get
the footage do you think this is
potentially interesting hassan or no
um i mean it's interesting because like
there's always going to be intrigue
surrounding like donald trump because
he's very telegenic and very charismatic
and also hot
um and people are just jealous of him
for those reasons
but other than that like i think at this
point i just want to see people go to
jail and because we're not going to see
any of these people go to jail because
while january the january 6 commission
is happening uh democrats in congress
are also simultaneously like trying to
cut deals with the republicans you know
what i mean to get legislation done
it's creating this like weird uh
hypocritical stance which exists in
politics to begin with that everyone
kind of intrinsically understands at
this point where you're like you can't
say these guys are trying to steal the
election which they did they did try
while simultaneously being like but we
also need to protect our institutions
and collaborate with them uh especially
when the other side doesn't even care
about collaborating for the most part
and routinely talks about how your baby
killers and baby eaters and stealing
elections
i've long
mentioned that the election theft what
msnbc liberals call the big lie
is not necessarily a big lie but instead
a very big part of the republican
campaign strategy and a republican
effort to undermine election security
and make it harder for people to go and
and actually vote especially in black
and brown neighborhoods in poor
neighborhoods in general because those
neighborhoods tend to vote for uh
democrats this is
uh you know most famously openly
admitted by paul weirich who is like the
head of the modern uh reactionary
conservative movement um he calls it the
the gugu government syndrome like where
he openly lays out in the moral majority
uh i think it was a moral majority
meeting in front of like richard nixon
ronald reagan he just openly states like
we don't want people to vote we want
less people to vote we win when less
people vote
so stop trying to get everybody to vote
uh and that is
actually uh here let's just play it
this is an incredibly profoundly
important foundation father of the
conservative movement addressed a
seminal religious right gathering held
in dallas yeah he created the moral
majority and also uh i think like
american enterprise institute and
numerous other like far right think
tanks that are prominent now
how many of our christians
have what i call the gugu syndrome
good government
they want everybody to vote
i don't want everybody to vote
elections are not won by a majority of
people they never have been from the
beginning of our country and they are
not now that's right as a matter of fact
our leverage in the elections quite
candidly goes up as the voting populace
goes down
and jerry falwell was there ronald
reagan was there wyrich co-founder of
the heritage foundation moral majority
free congress alec the american
legislative exchange council
and um and he's a really really
important figure for like an important
thought leader for the right
so
what do you think about this doc
documentary though you think i mean the
documentary is like interesting you have
hope that i could have something good
because every time something like this
comes up it always ends up being a
nothing burger but this time people seem
to have hope that it could be something
like really [ __ ] up that they actually
captured on film
i've lost hope a long time ago you want
to know why
everything that we found out so far that
we found out the new information that
came out is all stuff that we knew
already we knew this [ __ ] back in
january 6 when it was happening yeah i
mean there's a phone call of trump
saying
to the like georgian [ __ ]
person in charge of the election
uh i wanted to find me 7 000 more votes
i mean i don't know what more you need
to hear than that it doesn't matter
though like that it doesn't matter
because we have no the democrats are
feckless they are powerless
they are uh they're they're incapable of
doing anything
in a situation like this even our
attorney general said like yeah we're
watching closely but you know
don't don't hold out hope for for any
sort of serious survival they posted a
clip this morning i haven't actually
seen this this year did they already
yeah
my father he's very honest and he is who
he is he believes everything that he's
doing is right
i can't betray people
they don't treat me well in which case
you go to war
dude can we talk women about gender 6
i'm sorry the fact that this exists is
so [ __ ] funny to me
like he took it upon himself to hire a
[ __ ] film crew to document himself
trying to steal an election like
trump
is he's awesome
well apparently you were telling me
yesterday
that a lot of his advisors and stuff
didn't even know they're they're
claiming that i don't like yeah i don't
know
okay
i was like how is there a camera there
and people don't know it's there no they
of course they knew dude come on like it
but again they openly have been talking
about like stealing elections and like
stopping people from voting for a very
saying you're saying it's it's basically
the norm it's not out of the ordinary at
exactly donald trump's biggest mistake i
guess is actually what made him so
popular which is that he no longer had
these like weird veiled uh
institutionalist uh ways of of talking
about voter fraud which is not a real
thing um
and instead he just showed up said like
illegal mexicans are coming into the
country and they're stealing your votes
they're voting illegally democrats want
this to happen and for a lot of dumbass
americans there was like whoa
because they've been geared up to
believing that for a very long time or
some of them have been saying this
already on the [ __ ] ground and donald
trump was simply able to verbalize it in
a way that uh like paul ryan never would
get himself to say but but someone as
like uh respectable as paul ryan has
even uh talked about like election
results being fake and potential voter
fraud happening because
voter fraud is the only way
uh claiming that there's voter fraud
when no such voter fraud is happening is
the only way to justify election fraud
which is what republicans legitimately
do on a regular basis in order to stop
people from voting you have to first
create a problem if there's no such
problem you just lie and they've been
doing this for many many decades so it's
not new the only difference is donald
trump was saying it exactly how the way
people understood it on the ground
that's the big difference and that's why
he was able to build so much momentum
and that's why he was so popular as well
he spoke like the people
like me if there's footage of him being
like don't this is what the best case
scenario could be like
they're storming the capital sir we need
to call on the police he's like don't
call in the police just let it happen
like something like that right do you
think that would change people's minds i
mean something so undeniable
but that already exists yeah that's the
thing i want to watch this uh there's
only a few seconds
can we talk for a minute about january 6
that's it that's it you [ __ ] turkey
well so this is like a that looks like
it was an actual trailer for the
documentary itself what they subpoenaed
is the raw footage yeah bro i want to
see that so bad i wish please just
crowdsource this [ __ ] release all the
raw footage i don't think anything's
going to come out of it like there's no
way he could literally be like i know i
am stealing this election and i don't
care
kill mike pence what have you said i
want them to kill myself
liz cheney came out first day and said
that he literally said maybe he deserves
it trump said maybe he deserves it when
he heard the crowd saying uh mike pence
be hanging you know why because trump
much like many real americans hates
[ __ ] fake friends and mike pence is a
fake friend he's a fake best friend
it's not like none of these people don't
care about institutions they do not care
about the sanctity of institutions and
why should they the the government has
[ __ ] them over uh uh for a very long
time they only see the government as
like uh as like an authority that comes
in takes uh you know 30 of your paycheck
and then and then you know funnels it
into uh
subsidies to lifeless faceless
corporations or war so
of course people don't trust the
government of course people don't trust
the institutions of course they've like
congress is always historically uh
always unpopular they hate politicians
in general so for someone to come across
like an outsider even though they're not
they're [ __ ] real estate developer
clearly they were not an outsider the
most insider you can be
but someone who can like portray
themselves as an outsider
and say [ __ ] these institutions gives
people a lot of uh i guess hope uh it
justifies their anger it gives them um
you know it it gives them
they love trump for that reason because
they think he's like destroying these
institutions because no one on the
ground really [ __ ] cares about the
safety and security and sanctity of the
hallowed halls of congress i don't give
a [ __ ] do you do you care about congress
i don't give a [ __ ]
i mean
[ __ ] the congress [ __ ] the supreme court
people are like literally losing their
minds right now
chief justice john roberts oh my god the
the supreme court's uh you know the
integrity of the supreme court is under
threat it's like bro what are you
talking about do you know what the
federalist society is like how all of
your [ __ ] lackeys are are federalist
society activist judges uh this is a
this is an institution specifically
designed to put the most reactionary uh
republican justices in positions of
power and also pad the deck in the lower
courts so that they can undermine
uh
congress with obstructionist with an
obstructionist agenda which they very
successfully do sidestep congress and go
into state legislatures where they have
an overwhelming advantage as a
consequence of gerrymandered districts
uh and and right state legislation that
is completely unconstitutional have that
go through the court system all the way
to the supreme court where the six three
super majority of reactionary justices
vote in favor of not the democratic
opinion of the people not the majority
of the opinion of the people not what's
in the best interest of the legal and a
fair legal analysis yeah it's literally
political hackery it's crazy but it's
only been that way is what i'm saying
it's like that's kind of what it's been
i'm a fan of congress and theory you
know i there are certain things they
need to get rid of like the senate
filibuster just the senate in general
just get rid of the senate i mean if you
got rid of the filibuster
uh why should rhode island have
it's completely insane yeah california
has more constituents more voters than
like tennessee it's combined the idea of
it is that you know california gets more
house representatives and every state
gets equal rights i have less of a
problem with the house it's proportional
that makes sense but the senate isn't no
the house is also broken well
consequence of redistricting as well
right so like
they're they're breaking at least the
principle of the house yeah honestly
underlying i think they got rid of the
filibuster i'd like to see it just
functioning even in like the slightest
bit but the supreme court right now is
is like
a threat to
civilization i mean what they're doing
is is [ __ ]
absolutely insane this is a this is a
multi-decade project that's uh that's
finally
that's finally showing how successful it
is they're finally doing exactly what
they've been uh with these well you know
institutions are designed to do you know
what's funny they're always talking
about
the democratic
cabal i mean the federalist society is
literally a cabal they have worked in
the shadows behind the scenes to get
through people that are a member of a
cult literally who will they've become
judges they've gone to law schools and
they've been groomed to be a part of
this cult the federal federalist society
and get
and they elect presidents they they
elect senators and they streamline these
people
straight into the [ __ ] supreme court
you want to talk about a cabal and a
conspiracy i mean it's right here
in plain sight 1982 is when this uh when
this organization was founded 1982 from
1982 until now
um
they've been able to they've been able
to dramatically change
they've done good and work yeah they
i this was this became a major problem
when george w bush uh was going to
appoint a supreme court justice that he
knew i think like from
childhood or something right and the
federalist society sidestepped him and
said no you can't do this and they
actually put their own appointee
forward and ever since then i mean that
was i think like
that was the first instance where the
federalist society basically showcased
how powerful they were
and since then they've just every single
justices it has to be a federalist
society justice and they all have been
people are jokingly someone jokingly
said vote harder i mean look if trump
didn't win then this wouldn't have
happened i know but like remember
but we go back to if we're talking about
this from like our institutions have
failed us and it's time to recognize
that perspective which is the argument
i'm making you have to understand that
like george w bush did not win the
popular vote stole an election in
florida okay and was able to appoint
supreme court justices donald trump did
not win the popular vote one through the
electoral college and was able to
appoint supreme court justices like and
these guys have lifetime appointments
that's insane the lifetime appointment
thing used to go that doesn't make any
sense yeah well it's because how many
how many supreme court justices out of
the nine
have trump or bush appointed
it's got to be i think almost
yeah almost yeah like seven out of the
nine
trump picks like really young people
like the breck [ __ ] kavanaugh and
these all [ __ ] they're going to be on
this for like 50 years outside of one
all six right now are i think it's like
five of the
the everybody but
supreme court justices are are right a
trump or bush era picks what the [ __ ] is
what insane lifetime appointments how
does that make well the reason the
justification for it is uh that uh you
know this is a profoundly important
position and therefore it must be devoid
of polit of politics that it must not
interfere so
justices should not have like uh should
not have to like
get
like
curry political favor uh and and like
try to get reelected into that position
you know what i mean we'll avoid
elections
yeah you can appoint one every you know
10 years or something basically
they think that
in that circumstance supreme court
justices would not be they would be
ideologically bound to whoever is in a
position of power that will reappoint
them and therefore i mean i'm just
saying in theory it's [ __ ] i don't
think doesn't make any sense but that's
the theory the theory is yeah lifetime
appointment is insane like i can't
believe
the founders were so
that that that's just crazy bro so you
know what that's where the lifetime
formulas come from yeah it
idealistically i guess it makes sense
but i mean i don't even understand it
idealistically like i know the supreme
court's supposed to be devoid of
political leanings
and
that's good and all but i don't
understand how putting someone in that
position for life these people have no
accountability i mean they have no
[ __ ] repercussions or accountability
they can theoretically be impeached but
that will never [ __ ] happen yeah like
clarence thomas should be impeached
clearly his wife is jimmy thomas like
you're going back to the record [ __ ]
yeah going back to january 6 [ __ ] like
ginny thomas 100
influenced clarence thomas's decision
how could she know
yeah i mean she is like a psycho she was
involved in january 6 like insurrection
she she absolutely petitioned trump
uh at the time and and 100 like it's not
an accident that uh clarence thomas's
decision was the single stand-alone
decision on uh in
what was it hold on i'll i'll give you
the exact decision really yeah so
clarence thomas is a supreme court
justice appointed by bush is that right
yeah he he is the
thomas was the sole dissenter as uh
supreme court of the united states
allows trump's documentary the one that
we just saw to be seen by the january 6
committee he was the sole dissenter now
because there's a conflict of interest
there normally in lower court systems
there's an ethics there's a code of
conduct and an ethics violation that
lower courts have to abide by but
because the supreme court is only nine
supreme court justices and we treat them
like [ __ ] deities uh that they don't
have those same actual set of standards
they just uh
it's like a like a handshake agreement
that they will abide by lower court
ethics standards he needed to recuse
himself in the circumstance because of a
clear conflict of interest so his wife
was recently
exposed as being like a [ __ ] fringe
q anon mega cultist who was working to
overthrow the election this is the
supreme
court
justice's wife i mean this is insane
i mean if you think that's insane like
okay let's talk about something else
here real quick for the supreme court of
the united states ruth bader ginsburg
famously said like i love anthony scalia
right anthony scalia was a disgusting
petulant freak okay pig [ __ ] that died
swallowing a [ __ ] pillow at a hunting
lodge okay i don't even want to know
what the [ __ ] else he was doing out
there whatever godless he's burning in
hell if there is a hell anthony scalia
certainly is burning in it okay a shame
to italians all right now this
[ __ ] this was this actually was
like a very eye-opening moment for me
when i was taking a constitutional law
class in college and i was reading one
of his dissents about gay marriage
or antonin scalia famously in a
dissenting opinion uh against a gay
marriage wrote
uh the the classic slippery slope
logical fallacy where he basically said
if we allow gay marriage to exist what's
next a marriage between a man and and a
horse or a marriage between a man and a
dog that's [ __ ] and that
like he he compared gay marriage to
bestiality so understand that like these
people are not these incredible legal
scholars they're simply utilized they're
just reactionary pieces of [ __ ] that are
using a relatively new
um uh constitutional interpretation that
was totally made up okay
as a as a way to
as a way to basically create an
intellectual patina around reactionary
ideology that's that's it they want to
code it in like some kind of
intellectual uh examination when in fact
it's not it's just you're a republican
you're a conservative you want to hurt
gay people you don't want them to get
married so you're just you're just going
to vote against it you're going to
descend again give you context this guy
antonin scalia he was appointed by
reagan and this [ __ ] is ancient
history this man is a dinosaur and
that's why he's talking like these
insanely
homophobic takes that i guess were more
commonplace back then the man's a
dinosaur and he's still in the supreme
court with these dinosaur ideas he's not
accountable to anyone that's [ __ ]
insane it's so
crazy
yeah
but what was that quote pull up that
quote by uh
by
jenny guiney what's her name
ginny thomas yeah so this is uh justice
clarence's wife
she said help this great president stand
firm mark you are the leader with him
who is standing for america's
constitutional governance at the
precipice the majority knows biden and
the left is attempting the greatest
heist of our history
i mean you're just a crazy person
literally one by like five
seven million votes or something
awesome
that's the wife of a justice yeah it's
just uh you know there have been times
when the supreme court has been on the
right side of history when it comes to
civil liberties and whatnot and also not
specifically on the very wrong side of
history when it comes to civil liberties
back in the day three-fifths
but ultimately
like uh it is a it is a incredibly
undemocratic institution it completely
undermines like
uh the people's interests and these
supreme court justices every single
recent supreme court justice that was
appointed by donald trump straight up
lied on the stand
when they were when they were being
inducted or when their appointment
hearings were happening in the senate
and said
that roe v wade is the law of the land
it's a super precedent
that was a [ __ ] lie yeah that's crazy
they just straight up [ __ ] light and
there's no accountability and then like
the first thing they do
when they open their new session is like
let's get rid of this [ __ ]
yeah
so for chief justice john roberts to cry
about like the uh institution uh being
undermined you know the supreme court
being undermined as an institution that
is otherwise seen as infallible is a
silly one considering that this same
supreme court has done uh you know
horrific monstrous things before this
supposed draft leak that really really
hurt the supreme court like [ __ ] the
draft league the transit is meaningless
[ __ ] the supreme court i know scalia is
dead uh by the way i don't know
what
yeah yeah he [ __ ] died he croaked
like a little [ __ ] yeah i said like i
said he he died choking on him
loser
yeah but um
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh yeah so
everything's [ __ ] oh but so you're
saying the supreme court
ruled
that they could get this documented that
went to the supreme court yes it was so
the reason why i said clarence thomas is
like could be impeached i think there's
like grounds for impeachment for
clarence thomas is because he was the
sole dissenter
in
in a supreme court hearing where they
looked at whether or not the trump
documentary the one that we just saw
could be seen by the 1-6 committee yo
i'm kind of impressed that the other
guys voted to send it through though i
mean because like it's it's so
ridiculous dude come on that would have
been like there are certain things where
it's like it doesn't really matter why
does that even go to the supreme court
why does the committee need them to
approve that they can [ __ ] subpoena
documents
i guess they sued them right
to keep it yeah yeah they were trying to
block it right
yeah well there you have it they agreed
with the prior ruling that the former
president was unable to exert executive
privilege too because that's why that's
the main reason
yeah it would have set an incredible
precedent that like a former president
would be able to exert executive
privilege like that's insane so what did
what did clarence did he write an
opinion or did he just dissent quite so
my wife's not gonna [ __ ] me if i
it's my every wife's duty to sleep with
her husband
um
yeah what did he say let me see if i can
find his dissenting opinion on here but
oh it was not he was he didn't even
publish a dissenting opinion yeah
he's just like i don't i don't need to
explain myself just [ __ ] you all
yeah clarence oh boy
um all right i'm sorry to say but we are
out of time
i'm black built as [ __ ] dude
um we don't have time to get to the
story but cam has such a good graphic
that i feel like you guys just need to
see it um
you uh throw it up
ted cruz is a fake gamer girl true
it's true
yeah but uh we'll have to talk about it
next week or something
all right guys thanks for watching
black pill is ever tomorrow is friday
after dark we will be here at our
regular time
and having a fun ass good old time doing
it hassan thank you to you
sweet beautiful hassan
yes who we love so well yes
and thank you to all of the
beautiful members here
and shout out to alex uh mandel
oh boy [ __ ] boy
i take you on any time man
chat was addicts
no way better
oh no
[Music]
we're gonna hear this a lot more
[Music]
so
[Music]
you